The year 2020 might feel far away right now,
but that hasn't stopped Hollywood's major
studios from lining up a slew of projects
to compete for your movie budget, even a couple
years out.
Some of the upcoming releases on the calendar
are highly anticipated sequels, but that isn't
all we're expecting to see; the studios have
also set up new adaptations of existing properties
and all manner of would-be blockbusters, making
for what should be an epic year at the movies.
Start marking your calendar now, we've rounded
up an in-depth look at the biggest releases
coming along in 2020.
Bad Boys For Life
Seventeen years after the release of Bad Boys
2, audiences will finally get another entry
in the buddy cop franchise.
The film brings back Will Smith and Martin
Lawrence as Miami detectives Mike Lowrey and
Marcus Burnett, and the two couldn't be more
excited about working together again.
"I love that dude.
"He's a great guy."
"That's one of the best times I've had making
movies."
"I love Will."
"Damn come on Martin!"
"And Will loves me so we gonna do it."
While it's been a bumpy road to get the film
to the green light, it's full speed ahead
for the duo now, and a release date has been
set for January 17th.
G.I.
Joe: Ever Vigilant
Seven years after G.I.
Joe: Retaliation, everyone's favorite action
figure-based franchise is set to return.
It's unclear which, if any, of the original
movies' stars will return, as it's rumored
to be a reboot.
But considering the original cast included
everyone from Channing Tatum to Bruce Willis
to Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson, it's hard to
imagine we wouldn't see at least some of those
A-listers on the call sheet when movie three
gets ready for a March 27th debut.
Fast & Furious 9
By the time Fast and Furious 9 comes along,
fans of the speedy franchise will have gotten
their first spin-off, featuring Dwayne Johnson
and Jason Statham.
Although we don't know much about where the
saga's headed next, the pressure to keep upping
the stakes should mean it'll find a way to
be even more epic than previous installments.
With Charlize Theron's Cipher still alive
and on the loose at the end of Fate of the
Furious, there are lots of opportunities for
mayhem.
You can probably count on most of your favorite
cast members returning, and the franchise's
ever-increasing profile means there's always
the chance they'll land even more big names
to join the family.
Audiences will definitely want to drive out
to the theater on April 10th.
Godzilla vs. Kong
Film fans will finally get the answer to the
age-old question of which movie monster reigns
supreme when Godzilla and King Kong face off
on the big screen.
Director Adam Wingard has already assured
fans that his take on the two monsters will
crown a definitive winner, unlike the 1962
film that first put the two characters against
each other.
Although we still don't know which actors
will be part of the fun, there are sure to
be some A-listers on board when this epic
behemoth battle barrels into the summer box
office on May 22nd.
The Six Billion Dollar Man
Mark Wahlberg will help breathe cinematic
life into the '70s small screen series The
Six Million Dollar Man by giving the character
a raise to the Six BILLION Dollar Man.
Wahlberg will play Steve Austin, a former
astronaut who uses cutting-edge technology
to become half-machine in order to survive
after an accident, and uses his newfound superhuman
strength to work as a secret agent working
for the Office of Scientific Intelligence.
With its mix of robotics, espionage, and brute
physical force, The Six Billion Dollar Man
should be an event when it comes along on
June 5th.
Red Notice
Dwayne Johnson is set to re-team with director
Rawson Marshall Thurber, after working together
on Central Intelligence and Skyscraper, for
2020's action-comedy film Red Notice.
The movie will feature Johnson as an Interpol
agent chasing after the most wanted art thief
in the world.
We'll see if The Rock maintains his magic
streak at the movies when Red Notice hits
theaters on June 12th.
Indiana Jones 5
This installment of the Indiana Jones films
won't feature any lead-lined refrigerators
or ill-explained aliens, so if you weren't
a fan of Kingdom of the Crystal Skull, the
franchise's newest outing will get things
back on track for you.
Everyone involved seems to think the movie
will be a course correction, with Harrison
Ford saying he only wanted to return if the
script was great, and Steven Spielberg saying
he thinks the movie is, quote "straight down
the pike for the fans."
"It's great fun to play this character.
It's great fun to work with Steven.
I'm looking forward to it."
There's a lot of potential for the future
of the franchise, and the next film seems
like it could bring back the adventure of
the original trilogy when it arrives on July
10th.
Bios
Tom Hanks will be the last man on Earth in
this sci-fi outing.
Specific plot details for Bios are being kept
tightly under wraps, but we do know that Hanks'
character, Finch, is an ailing inventor and
the last man left on this planet, who builds
a robot to protect his beloved dog after his
death.
Although we don't have many concrete details
yet, Hanks has shown us many, many times that
he's the right guy to lead up any kind of
survival story, even completely solo, so count
on this one to be a must-watch on October
2nd.
Fantastic Beasts 3
While we're still waiting to see what happens
in the second Fantastic Beasts and Where to
Find Them movie, Warner Bros. is already gearing
up for the third film in the franchise.
Very little is known about the film at this
point, but the series definitely got off to
an encouraging start, with the first film
earning solid reviews and healthy box office
returns.
With the second movie bringing in even more
Harry Potter connections and the third likely
to build on that further, November 20th is
a date you'll want to pencil in on your calendar
for more movie magic to come.
Avatar 2
We're getting four Avatar sequels over the
next decade, so a lot rides on the first one
doing well when it hits theaters in 2020.
James Cameron's massive undertaking reportedly
has a total budget of over $1 billion, allowing
the director to fully embrace new technology
and make sure that the sequels are as visually
stunning as the first chapter.
The movies are said to be a family saga about
Jake, Neytiri, and their children, with many
of the film's original cast returning as well.
Newcomers to the franchise include Cliff Curtis
and Oona Chaplin as additions to the Pandora
collective, which will return to theaters
December 18th.
Sherlock Holmes 3
Robert Downey Jr. is set to return for a third
outing as the world's most famous detective
in a film that will also feature the return
of his co-star Jude Law as John Watson.
It's unclear if Guy Ritchie, who directed
the first two films, will return, but since
it's been nine years since Downey last played
the character in A Game of Shadows, it should
be interesting to see how his take on Sherlock
Holmes has aged when this new leg of the adventure
hits theaters December 25th.
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3
Last but certainly not least, Marvel is expected
to bring back their intergalactic team of
misfits with Guardians of the Galaxy Vol.
3.
It's unclear who will return following the
events of Avengers: Infinity War, but we do
know it's supposed to offer an "epic conclusion"
to the saga of the Star-Lord's ragtag squadron
while helping to potentially launch the next
phase of the Marvel Cinematic Universe.